on passe à la dernière info du jour on
va revenir sur la mystérieuse
disparition de l'acteur Marwan berini
connu pour son rôle d'Abdel dans la
série Plus Belle d'Ave plus personne n
de ses nouvell depuis le 3 août dernier
he de fou on le rappelle la nuit de sa
disparition la voiture qui lui a qui lui
appartient à percuter une femme de 38
ans à Maon mais impossible de savoir si
l'acteur était au volant puisqu'il est
toujours introuvable à leur on parle
c'est incroyable ça n'avance pas on a
l'impression l'enquête n'avance pas Gil
Verdez aujourd'hui on apprend que Marwan
aurait peut-être fui vers la Suisse
après l'accident donc ça rebondit et les
parents de la acteur on publie une
lettre bouleversante à leur fils je vais
vous dire la lettre dans un instant
petit reccap et on en parle juste
après cela fait de mois que le mystère
autour de Marwan bereni reste entier
l'acteur Marwan bereni a disparu des
radars le 3 août dernier pour rappel
l'homme qui a incarné Abdel Fedala dans
la série Plus Belle La Vie est suspecté
d'avoir renversé une femme au volant de
son véhicule et d'avoir pris la fuite il
n'a depuis ce jour donné aucune nouvelle
les parents vous savez ils ont une
volonté que tout soit mis en œuvre pour
que leur fils soit retrouvé en détresse
ses parents viennent de sortir du
silence en publiant une lettre dans le
journal Libération alors que contient ce
courrier on en parle ce soir dans
TPMP donc les parents de Marouan euh ont
écrit une lettre Gill Verdez je vais
dire la lettre après vous allez nous
donner les derniers éléments d'accord
Marouan si tu penses que tu as besoin
d'aide pour chasser ce nuage sombre qui
plane au-dessus de toi et te fait
ressentir tristesse et désespoir pour
que tout aille mieux demain Marwan notre
fils affronte tes peurs tu as le droit
de pleurer mais reprends ton chemin
crois en toi crois en tes rêves même
ceux que tu ne prononces pas murmure les
mots qui réconfortent tu les connais
fais-toi confiance sache que toutes les
tempêtes ne viennent pas forcément
gâcher notre vie tu es unique tu es
formidable on aime ton rire on aime ton
sourire Marwan simplement nous t'aimons
et croyons en toi reviens on a besoin de
toi
donc ils sont ils pensent donc que
Marwan d'après cette lettre est parti à
cause de ces démons et de la peur
d'affronter des choses c'est ça des ches
absolument la peur d'affronter des
choses aussi il allait pas très bien
quelques mois avant l'accident puis là
ça allait mieux parce que Plus belle la
vie allait repartir il savait qu'il
aurait un rôle phare sans doute le
premier rôle donc ils se disent que il
s'est passé quelque chose et pour écrire
ça on s'est dit d'abord peut-être
ont-ils une information selon le
laquelle il est vivant mais non ils
n'ont pas d'information et c'est ce
qu'il déplore aussi dans cette lettre
c'est que le parquet de Macon qui dirige
l'enquête ne donne aucune info la
justice ne donne rien alors pourquoi la
justice est critiquée très critiquée
c'est parce que les enquêteurs ont cru
qu'il allait revenir au départ ils n'ont
rien fait parce qu'ils se sont dit
disparition inquiétante ok mais il va
revenir et il ne revient pas alors cyil
on en sait maintenant un peu plus quand
même alors selon les informations du
journal de sonéoir l'acteur aurait pris
la décision de la la direction de la
Suisse après l'accident oui on en sait
un peu plus sur toute la nuit du drame
donc en fait quand il est au fameux club
à Maon il arrive à 23h il repart à 23h10
c'est sûr ce qu'on sait maintenant c'est
que cinq témoins l'ont vu et on sait
aussi que très vraisemblablement c'est
lui qui conduit le véhicule
d'ailleurs une grosse info d'ailleurs ce
véhicule est un véhicule que l'on dit le
courtoisie qui ne lui appartient pas qui
est immatriculé dans les Bouches du rô
ça c'est une info et qui lui a été prêté
donc après il s'en va est-ce qu'il va
chez lui à Fuissé ou est-ce qu'il va à
Fleury là où est déposé la voiture et où
elle sera retrouvé on ne le sait pas ce
qu'on sait c'est que la dernière trace
de lui c'est le smartphone le lendemain
4 août à 13h28 et après plus rien et
maintenant donc moi j'ai eu le le
journal de son son et Loir ils sont
absolument certains qu'un ami est venu
le chercher et que cet ami l'a emmené en
Suisse ils sont formels ils ne me l'ont
pas dit officiellement mais j'ai
l'impression que les enquêteurs à
quièent à cette thèse également ce qu'
ouais on on va reprendre les les infos
dans un temps mais il y a également ça
accompagne qui avait réagi elle aussi 10
jours après après l'accident sur insta à
tous les
curieux Gilles qu'est-ce qu'il a
dit c'est pas écrit
lemertoi c'est pas écrit sur l'affiche
c'est pour ça il s piégé tout seul c'est
pas écrit c'est écrit derrière mais
c'est pas écrit sur
l'affiche derrière à tous les curieux
arrête de m'engueuler quoi c'est pas non
plus
[Applaudissements]
à tous les curieux mais surtout tous les
gens qui tiennent des propos déplacés
concernant Marwan ou ma manière de gérer
l'événement pourquoi elle avait dit ça
elle avait dit ça parce que on a
l'impression que la famille s'est murée
dans le silence que la famille en fait
n'était pas totalement derrière lui que
peut-être la famille savait des choses
et qu'elle ne disait pas et la famille
avait choisi le silence et aujourd'hui
la famille veut parler parce que la
famille a l'impression que quelque chose
est su quelque part par les enquêteurs
et qu'on leur cache oui il ne supporte
pas que les enquêteurs ne leur parl pas
des parents pour moi elle donne de
l'espoir elle donne de l'espoir
exactement est-ce que vous pensez qu'ils
ont des infos ou pas du tout non alors
je je me suis renseigné c'est ça parce
que moi la la lettre des parents je je
je pense très fort à eux forcément ilent
des moments difficiles mais leur lettrre
oui elle donne de l'espoir on se dit
qu'il est il est quelque part il est
vivant il a peur de quelque chose alors
comme elle donne de l'espoir au moment
où on apprend qu'il est en Suisse je me
suis demandé si c'était pas une
coïncidence ou non et c'est une
coïncidence c'est-à-dire que les parents
avant que le journal de son Loir ne
sorte l'info ne savait pas qu'il était
en Suisse les parents sont tenus dans
l'ignorance alors maintenant cyil une
des questions qui reste à poser c'est
comment marwine berenny a-t-il prévenu
son ami parce que si c'est par son
téléphone si c'est par son téléphone son
ami qui ven am qui est venu le
chercheraccord ah oui ah oui ah oui oui
ce ne serait pas un ami de Macon c'est
un ami de Paris ou de Suisse mais donc
il l'a appelé dans la nuit pourquoi les
enquêteurs n'ont pas encore identifié
cet ami ça c'est les questions et ils
l'ont pas identifié donc estce est-ce
qu'il a pris un autre téléphone est-ce
qu'il y avait une troisème personne mais
est- qu'on est sûr de ça alors la Suisse
honnêtement les gens du journal ENF
c'est eux qui sortent toutes les infos
depuis le début je les ai eu ils sont
sûrs de leur inf qu'il est parti en
Suisse qui vous avez eu qui en Suisse
non j'ai eu le journal de sonir c'est en
France ils sont sûr de leur infos
franchement il est parti en Suisse
est-ce qu'il y est encore est-ce qu'il y
est resté on sait pas donc là c'est des
infos quand même importantes mais c'est
des infos extrêmement importantes c'est
que il y a une disparition volontaire de
sa part sans doute choqué il a appelé un
ami en lui disant emmène-moi loin j'ai
fait une grosse bêtise une grosse
connerie vous me passerez parce que ça
écarte quand même la tèse du suicide
éorme sont sur de TR bien je ser
rassuré c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
après qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en
Suisse voilà est-ce qu'il a besoin de
mais pourquoi il aurait fu donc pourquoi
de quoi de quoi il parle c'est pas
panique panique panique après ce qui
s'est passé sil est vraiment au volant
parce que vous avez dit a priori il
serait il aurait été au volant de ah oui
je je le laisse au conditionnel mais on
peut presque l'enlever les enquêteurs on
sont sûr c'est les enquêteurs ils sont
sûr de ça d'accord donc
voilài donc ses parents pensent a priori
la lettre ils ont ils doivent avoir des
éléments que vous avez des enquêteur les
parents je suis pas sûr parce que les
parents ils se plainent du manque de
contact il y a des parquets on voit sur
d'autres affaires qui communiquent en
permanence des procureurs qu'on voit à
la télé et là rien du tout donc ça
étonne quand même mais sur la Suisse on
est oui on est on est sûr qu'il est
parti en Suisse et les enquêteurs
pensaient qu'il allait revenir mais pour
le moment il y a pas de trace de lui
donc en fait les enquêteurs Savit que
c'était lui qui conduisaitou il savaiit
qu'il était parti enens suite
hisseant attend on attend voilà et ils
ont beau attendre il ne se passe rien
mais g les enquêteurs ils corroborent la
version des journalistes il disent eux
aussi qu'il est parti en Suisse ou c'est
les journalistes que j'ai eu avec qui
j'ai discuté aujourd'hui ils ont une
source extrêmement fiable pour le moment
à chaque fois qu'ils ont sorti une info
c'était toujours vrai voilà ils sont ils
sont persuadés qu'il a pris la direction
de la Suisse voilà donc là on espère ça
serait génial qu'il soit en Suisse et
qu'il soit vivant alors qu'il soit
vivant en Suisse ou ailleurs est-ce
qu'il est revenuus caché est-ce qu'il y
a autre chose parce que tout le monde
lui a fait des appels il a SRA fille qui
a renversé lui a dit voilà je pr à
pardonner elle envie de voir Enie de par
sa compagne ses parents un moment
qu'est-ce qu' risque en fait il risque
quoi alors pour le moment il est
simplement recherché comme témoin puis
que il y a pas
officiell mais il a raison Jean-Michel
si c'est lui qui conduis est sû que
c'est lui il va pas prendre 20 ans de
prison c'est lui qui conduit de la
prison avec surc peut-être il pourra
avoir peut-être de la prison avec surc
je P peut-être une peine de prison ferme
il peut risquer une peine de prison
ferme mais je suis pas sûr qu'il l'est
quoi mais il faudrait qu'il s'excuse
qu'il revienne Sandra qu'on avait
entendu ici lui avait lancé un appel
pour qu'il revienne voilà maintenant
tout le monde attend on aimerait
vraiment qu'il revienne par on sait
jamais s nous regarde Marwan c'est un
garçon que tous les gens qui l'ont
rencontré en plus trouve qu'il est
exceptionnel disent que c'est un garçon
génial un amour de mec et c'est vrai que
voilà la Sandra elle a elle nous a
laissé des messages aussi elle lui a
laissé des messages la jeune fille qui a
été percutée elle aimerait vraiment le
voir elle aimerait lui parler et je
pense voilà que si revenz ça serait pas
dramatique enfin serait pas dramatique
écas par laabilité aussi que plus il
attend plus c'est compliqué pour lui de
revenir qu'il va retrouver son travail
estce qu'il va pouvoir être travailler
être blacklisté complètement partout où
il va
aller c'est sûr oui mais bon un moment
un moment oui voilà il va réapparaître
sil dit les choses s'il prend ses
responsabilités s'il voit son dras et
que voilà en vrai voilà c'est c'est
c'est c'est je pense qu'il il devrait
revenir enfin j'espère moi qu'il est
vivant et qu'il va revenir qu'il a pas
fait une connerie parce que voilà c'est
pas non
plus après il était déjà meurtri de par
le passé donc je pense aussi que
psychologiquement il fonctionne pas
comme quelqu'un qui qui n'a jamais rien
vécu et ça peut être très compliqué
d'analyser tout de prendre du recul s'il
a pas de bons conseils est tout se
important la l de ses parents dit peut
ça va faire bouger les choses oui elle
est important mais moi je la trouve un
peu en décalage par rapport aux
événements c'est une d'amour de parents
pour leur enfant il y a pas un mot de
compassion pour
pas Glot
espant final
FS dans ch à tout de suite mes
Vich